hey welcome to reason with Kennedy I'm
Kennedy bringing reason and rationality
to an insane chaotic world devoid of any
logic Whitney Houston is dead it's no
surprise to Whitney Watchers the last
sad 15 years but it is sad the songbird
met her demise in the tub and too close
to the Grammys for a well planned
send-off if she only had the good sense
to OD on xanax and Heineken even a few
days earlier there could have been a
more fitting tribute whenever an icon is
taken from us whether it's Michael
Jackson Anna Nicole Smith or Heath
Ledger people's first response usually
is there ought to be a loss but you know
what there are already too many lives
that's not the problem it's the sad
cocktail of Fame and addiction that
doesn't mean every time the only
cassandra spouting an ounce of sense was
crooning codger Tony Bennett take a look
I'd like to have every gentleman and
lady in this room commit themselves to
get our government to legalize drugs Oh
granted Tony can sound nuttier than
squirrel turds when spouting 9/11
conspiracies but here he's more on
target than Mohammed Atta when it comes
to drug legalization whatever else we
can say about Whitney Houston's swan
song we know this much drug prohibition
didn't make it any easier for her or for
any of us to deal with substance abuse
problems the Grammys may not have been
Whitney's big night but it was a big
night for a big girl the rubenesque
songstress Adele she swept all six of
her Grammy categories for which she can
send a handwritten thank-you note to
anorexic former fatty fashion designer
Karl Lagerfeld the skeleton in chief for
the House of Chanel called Adele a
little too fast it was just enough to
coalesce Grammy votes in Adele's favor
all the while solidifying love for the
fat girl who sings the Beautiful
somebody done somebody wrong songs Karl
Lagerfeld
- suck it but he probably won't swallow
to save the calories does every woman
have to be a rail-thin coke [ __ ] to
have value here's a woman who's
beautiful authentic and talented beyond
her 23 years who essentially told the
fascist fashionista to piss up a rope
the weight of public opinion was on
Adele
because people are increasingly fed up
with heavy-handed social engineering
disguised as do-gooder isms the same
goes for Michelle Obama's misguided and
hypocritical let's move campaign to
skinny up the girls and boys we
constantly see the Obamas eating high
fat foods in public which is their
absolute right but it's a little bit
much to see Michelle dancing with school
kids in an effort to nudge the body mass
index and her preferred direction it
starts with a hula hooping first lady
but it ends with a government banning
trans fat salt swag Roth
caffeinated alcoholic beverages and
everything else that makes the world a
little tastier oh yeah she can pry this
can of caffeinated for loco from my cold
dead hand after I split it with Adele
this one's for you girl
you